hi today we're going to be talking a
little bit more about the motherboard
now the motherboard we mentioned briefly
in the video about basic hardware but
we're going to go into a little bit more
detail today so what makes a motherboard
is the connection between the CPU and
the memory if there's no connection
between the central processing unit and
the memory we can't call it a
motherboard but most motherboards do a
lot more than that
primarily may have expansion slots and
ports now expansion slots are where you
put anything that can increase the
performance of the computer without
putting more load on the CPU for example
a graphics or a sound card would up your
user experience by giving you a better
video or better sound quality but it
wouldn't slow down anything that the CPU
had to do a network interface card could
also go in an expansion slot this would
help your computer connect with the
networks around it we'll talk about
networks a little bit more in videos
coming up now a PC card which has really
been turned mostly over to express cards
are found primarily in laptops because
of the size express current is better
it's just much smaller in addition to
expansion slots motherboards have ports
now on your computer I'm sure you know
there's a place where you can plug in a
USB cord firewire SD card Ethernet even
an audio plug in so you can listen
through headphones now these are all
considered ports a place on the
motherboard where you can connect the
CPU to some outside source either to get
or give information so just a quick
review of the motherboard at its very
minimum connects the CPU and the memory
but it also has expansion slots and
ports